she is an assistant professor at Harvard
and she has done a a lot of very
interesting work on trustworthy ML and
she's going to talk tell us about some
of this work today and she was unable to
be here in person so she's presenting
remotely Hima it's great to have you and
please take off thank you
thank you so much
um hi everyone thanks so much for
joining me today in this talk today I'm
going to talk about some of our recent
research on navigating the disagreement
problem in explainable ml and I'm going
to talk about what this problem is and
you know what am I talking about when I
say the disagreement problem and much
more throughout this talk so the layout
or the agenda for this talk would be
I'll just spend like the first 10 or so
minutes giving like a brief overview of
the different methods that are commonly
used when people try to explain uh
machine learning models in a post-talk
fashion and then I'll go into some of
our recent work which involves user
studies with practitioners and the
challenges they face when working with
these methods and then the last part
would be some of the solutions that were
outlined in a recent Europe's papers
so with that I'm going to get started
with some of the motivation first
all right uh so I think this is not new
to the folks sitting here or the
community here that you know machine
learning models are increasingly being
considered for deployment in a lot of
complex high-stakes decision making
settings for example settings like
healthcare or law or Finance especially
in terms of loan approvals and so on
right so a lot of these kinds of
settings are using machine learning
models more and more so now that that is
the case so why or how can model
understanding be useful is a question
that's important to today's talk because
it's a lot about explainable machine
learning or understanding model
predictions right so first of all these
are all high stakes decision making
settings so any decisions that are made
in these kinds of settings have impact
on human lives you know health of people
finances of people as well as companies
and these settings are often relatively
well uh relatively less well studied
which means the models that we are
building training and deploying in these
settings are not as extensively
validated for example compared to models
that we see on online portals whether it
is Netflix or Amazon or Goodreads and so
on right so this is a relatively less
well-studied setting that we are dealing
with but also quite important and in
given that this is the setting that we
are considering accuracy alone is no
longer enough because the training and
testing data that we may use to develop
these models may not be representative
of what will actually show up once the
model is deployed in practice right and
there are also some auxiliary criteria
which become very critical for example
non-discrimination right to explanation
safety and so on and a lot of times
these auxiliary criteria are even hard
to quantify right so it's impossible to
predict or enumerate all the scenarios
where you know we are violating safety
or the model is violating safety in the
context of autonomous driving for
example so in some sense there is this
kind of model understanding the purpose
of it comes to the fore or its utility
becomes critical when there is some kind
of incompleteness in problem formulation
or problem formalization right so just
to kind of summarize so model
understanding is often critical when
models that we are looking at are not
extensively validated in the application
settings uh which means there is a risk
that the train and test data may not be
representative of the data encountered
once the models are deployed uh in real
world setting and also the second reason
why model understanding can be very
useful or critical is when the key
criteria are often hard to quantify and
we need to rely on you will know it when
you see it kind of an approach so that's
where the power of model understanding
our explanations come to the fore right
just to give a few quick examples for
those of you who might be slightly new
to this area so for example let's say
there's a predictive model which engines
patient details for example you know
patient age and then their symptoms and
you know their past health history maybe
their family health history and produces
a prediction of if the patient is at
covert risk or not
um and a doctor who's at the receiving
end of a prediction like this so in some
sense that the doctor just sees that the
model has made this one single
prediction of the patient is at risk of
covid that may not be as helpful to the
doctor but if the doctor actually sees
what are the key features that the model
is focusing on then he or she might be
able to determine how to use this
prediction that the model is making
right so how much to rely on it how much
to agree with the prediction or if the
doctor should go ahead and make their
own decision right so in this case what
we see is you know appointment day and
time seem to be showing up as some of
the top features that are guiding this
prediction which basically makes the
doctor is enough to make the doctor
skeptic of this particular prediction
and then the doctor may decide to not
trust it and make his or her own
prediction right so in this case model
understanding is helping the doctor's
essays if and when to trust model
predictions when making the critical
distance that they make and another
scenario that we can think of and this
is another popular area of exploration
in explainable machine learning is this
piece where uh you know there are loan
applicants who submit their applications
to Banks Banks employ predictive models
which in turn determine if a particular
loan application should be approved or
not right so oftentimes an applicant
will just get to know the decision which
is your application is approved or not
without a lot of further context but if
only you know there were more details
provided for example increase your cell
salary by a certain amount or pay your
credit card bill on time for the next
three months and then you will get a
loan right so some kind of uh more
prescriptive recommendations are
provided to the loan applicants then
that can actually be beneficial so in
some sense here model understanding is
helping provide recourse to individuals
who are adversely affected by model
predictions right and this is actually a
question yep
here
um so so so in this example
um with the recourse there are some
things applicant can maybe feasibly do
in some things they they can't for
example it's pretty easy to like you
know pay your bills on time it's less
easy to be like I'm going to like you
know dramatically increase like salary
um do you do do you think about like a
distinction between these two in your
work in terms of thing things that are
like reasonably actionable and those
which are not yeah for sure a great
question Rachel yes and I think that is
one of the key components that goes into
the design of the so-called algorithmic
recourses or counterfactual explanations
uh which is the cost that is required to
achieve a particular recourse right and
that is kind of captured as an integral
part of the objective functions that we
try to optimize for sure but there is a
lot more to that because oftentimes
these costs might not not be sort of
very simple to grasp right so of course
we can sort of make a general assumption
that you know maybe for the entire
population this is what like maybe
changing salary might be harder or you
know maybe paying your credit card bills
might be easier and so on but there are
lots of nuances there because the cost
itself can depend on individual where
they stay their circumstances and all of
that right so we have while I'm not
going to go into detail in that but like
we have some recent work which basically
focuses on getting pairwise comparison
from individuals for example we show
them two features and ask them you know
different kinds of changes about okay if
you if you have to change your salary or
increase it by 20K versus if you have to
pay your credit card bill on time which
one is easier for you to do so asking a
lot of such pairwise comparison
questions extracting the data and then
learning the costs associated with each
change and then incorporating them into
the objectives is something that we have
done but yeah a very important piece
here
all right so I'm going to keep us moving
so uh in this case modern understanding
is helping provide recourse to
individuals who are adversely affected
by model predictions right so that's yet
another uh usage uh and uh model
understanding or rather the right to
explanation has also become a popular
topic of conversation in a lot of
regulatory recommendations as well as
these bills that are coming out whether
it is the AI bill that recently came out
from the US or the gdpr from Europe and
so on right so for example in those
cases if there are models uh which
basically take some input data and
output a bunch of predictions but we
also at a high level understand what the
model might be doing for example you
know for females the model might be
looking at ID numbers for males the
model might be looking at you know true
correct symptoms in this case such an
understanding can also help regulatory
authorities uh figure out if the model
is even ready to be right so in this
case the model is using spurious
features on all of the females so it's
not really a very credible model in
terms of deploying it at scale right so
this kind of model understanding also
allows us to wet models to determine if
they're suitable for deployment in real
world applications okay and lastly so
far we have been talking quite a bit
about you know these high-stakes
settings where of course a model
understanding can be very helpful to the
decision makers involved to the
customers or the end users involved in
that pipeline as well but beyond that
model understanding can actually be very
useful to all of us who develop machine
learning models on a regular basis and
the way it can be helpful for us is with
respect to debugging for example if
there is a model that's ingesting images
as inputs and uh spitting out
predictions for example the name of the
animal that occurs in this image in this
case Siberian Husky all of this seems
right so far but examining what are the
features that the model is focusing on
for instance in this case uh the model
is seen to be focusing on the snow in
the image when making this prediction
that basically tells the developer or
the engineer or the researcher here who
is building that model that it is
actually relying on spurious features in
this case we have probably developed a
snow detector as opposed to uh you know
a model that is supposed to or it was
designed to predict the animals in the
images but it is predicting whether
there is snow or not right so clearly
there is work to do in terms of going
back and uh you know rebuilding the
model or fixing these kinds of issues
but essentially in this case model
understanding is facilitating debugging
right another question uh sorry to
interact yeah this is Lydia Liu and I
had a question actually about how do you
determine which features are Xperia's is
this
um like in the earlier example of
um predicting I think in the healthcare
example like if you were saying in the
day and time are sort of irrelevant
features but if you uh I could also
Imagine a situation where maybe like the
models using some information about
other people who were infected with
covid who had the appointment the same
day so how like it seems difficult to
know a priority which things are
experienced if you didn't know maybe why
the model was using them and sort of
maybe the Siberian Husky example to is
sort of relevant because like uh the
environment might be considered like a
okay
feature to use to determine the species
right yeah no I think uh certainly right
so what is furious is often highly
context dependent so in this case the
way at least for the sake of these
simpler examples the way one could think
about them or the reason why I'm calling
them spirit is because you know if we
sort of apply these kinds of models to a
lot more of a generic sample uh then
they may start failing right so the
model might be using appointment day and
time which is the signal that it is
finding in the training data in order to
make this prediction but at the same
time they may not be generalizable right
and the doctor knows it very well or
even I think you know several of us can
agree that yeah it's such a model if I
deploy it now and if I'm letting it run
forever maybe that's that's not going to
be as generalizable maybe it's
overfitting to be uh subparts of the
training data right so that's why we are
sort of thinking of them as Furious but
you're right that the definition of
spurious itself is a bit context
dependent and in fact I would argue that
that's why we need to show whatever the
model is doing to uh the end users or
the decision makers and they can use
their domain expertise to sort of
determine if this is even reasonable and
then make an informed decision
okay so now that we have talked a little
bit about the different scenarios where
model understanding can be helpful uh
just at a high level I want to describe
a couple of strategies that have been
followed in recent literature to
actually achieve model understanding
right so the first one of them is to
build models or predictive models that
are inherently interpretable the
simplest case of this is something like
building linear models or shallow trees
or shallow rule sets which are
essentially models that are of course
designed to make predictions but are
also simple enough that we can all look
at the model in its entirety and then
see what the model is doing and how it
is assigning labels to different data
points right of course there have also
been more complex attempts in recent
times for example there have been Works
which try to add attention layers to
deep neural networks or certain kinds of
prototype layers to deep neural networks
and they can all also be thought of as
inherently interpretable models but but
there is also work showing that there
are challenges associated with doing
that as well and we don't know if the
attention layers are actually capturing
the right interpretations right so for
now maybe we can think of these simpler
models that are unambiguous we all can
see the model we all can see what the
model is doing and these are inherently
interpretable and building them is one
option right the second option which has
become very very popular in the last
five years or so is to explain any given
pre-built model in a post-hoc fashion
right so for example there could be a
black box model and we don't see any of
the internal details of this model we
just see the data points that are being
we throw a data point at it and we just
see the prediction made by the model or
there could be just complex models like
you know deep knits with several
intermediate layers so such models you
sort of pass them through explainer
algorithms and they in turn break these
complex models down into much simpler
models which we can again understand
right so in some sense we build a model
as complex as needed with the highest
possible accuracy but we explain those
models in a post-hop fashion with
simpler models so this this area or the
set of techniques which do that are
called post hoc explanation methods and
they have been pretty popularly uh used
or popular in the last few years
so now the question comes like when we
have these two strategies like which one
to go with or like what to do right so
which one to employ in some sense the
rationale behind why even post talk
explanation method started becoming more
and more popular in the last five years
or so is this kind of a trade-off curve
uh where a lot of Studies have started
observing that simpler models like
linear models are shallow decision trees
are of course more interpretable will
but they are not as accurate as models
like deep knits with several
intermediate layers right so that's one
of the reasons and the second reason is
that a lot of times companies are
developing these proprietary Black Box
models uh none of us none of the
external folks even get access to the
internal details of the model all that
happens is this model is just put out
somewhere it can spit predictions if we
send inputs to it but beyond that we
don't really know what the model is
doing or how it was constructed right so
given these two cases where there seem
to be trade-offs between accuracy and
interpretability but also in some cases
we just have access to a proprietary
black box that we need to understand to
serve these two situations post-hoc
explanations have sort of come about and
these are the situations where it might
be beneficial to use post-hoc
explanations or postdoc explanation
methods right the rest of the stock will
focus on post talk explanation methods
uh so and from here on I'm going to
describe one very popular category of
postdoc explanation methods and the
research I'm going to talk about from
here on will also focus on those that
class of noise
all right the class of methods that I
was just referring to is called feature
attribution based local explanation
methods these methods are designed to
generate what we can call as local
explanations that is explain individual
predictions of any given classifier
and these methods typically output
feature attributions or feature
importances for individual instances and
these feature attributions capture the
impact or contribution of each feature
on a given Black Box prediction right so
we are not explaining anything globally
so we are not trying to explain the
entire model what we are trying to
explain is for a given prediction uh
these kinds of explanation methods
generate you know feature importances
associated with each of the features for
that particular prediction right for a
single prediction and it's examples of
some very commonly used methods in this
category are lime shop gradient gradient
times input smooth grad and integrated
gradients so all of these methods they
do different things but essentially they
sort of output feature attributions or
feature importances for each feature for
a given prediction okay uh at a very
high level just flying is one of the
first approaches that even started this
entire category of post-hoc explanation
methods and the logic behind how this
functions is actually pretty simple
right so let's say we are trying to
explain the prediction of this point
that we see here which is x i right the
way line approaches this problem is to
basically first sample the points around
x i so you take a point and then you
basically perturb x i and generate
samples from the neighborhood of x i
okay and there you get a bunch of
samples around exercise so essentially
you generate perturbations of a given
point and then you use the underlying
predictive models whose prediction we
want to explain to label these samples
that we have just generated around x i
right so we get labels of all of these
points and then essentially where these
samples according to the distance to the
original Point such that points that are
closest to the original point we care
about have higher weights and points
that are farther away from the original
point we care about have lower weights
and then once we do that we essentially
fit like a simple linear regression
model on these weighted samples and that
linear regression model will essentially
give us the feature importances or the
attributions that we care about which
can then be shown to the users right so
this is a pretty simple approach to sort
of like you know going from the super
complex neural network with several
hundreds of intermediate layer to just
kind of saying that yeah locally at
least for each prediction I can tell
what are some of the important features
or the feature attributions associated
with that prediction of course it has
its own challenges and that has been
explored quite a bit in the literature
but the intuition that this approach
exploits is that even a model with a
very complex non-linear decision
boundary globally e can be approximated
using simple linear models locally right
so irrespective of how non-linear the
global surface of the model is if you
zoom in enough you know you'll be able
to find a small area where you can
approximate the model using a linear
model right so this complex model
locally using a linear model so that's
one approach and sharply values or shap
is basically another approach that was
proposed which essentially takes a game
theoretic perspective to determining
these feature importances here this
approach tries to compute the marginal
contribution of each feature towards a
given prediction averaged over all
possible permutations of the features
right so that's that's how it determines
the attribution of or the contribution
of each feature to a given prediction
and then there is input gradient which
is essentially you take the gradient
with respect to a given point x whose
model prediction you care about and that
will tell you like what features of that
input X are actually important in
determining the prediction right then
there is smooth grad which is
essentially the smoothing of the
gradients instead of just Computing the
gradient with respect to one point x you
sort of like take several perturbations
of that point x and compute gradients
with respect to all of those and compute
the average of those values and that
will give you a bit more of a smooth
gradient value which will again tell you
what is the importance of each of the
pixels in the image with respect to this
prediction that's coming up right and
integrated gradients is a different kind
of smoothing technique compared to the
smooth grad the idea here is that you
sort of take again this kind of a sum of
interpolated gradients so you have a
baseline image and you have the image
whose prediction you want to explain and
then you sort of interpolate the
gradients on that path between those two
and that will give you another version
of like a smooth gradient and that is
used as an explanation to determine
which pixels are contributing to the
prediction that's being produced by the
model right and the last one is gradient
times input essentially compute the
gradient of the function with respect to
a point a X but also multiply the point
x to that so that's another variant that
has been considered so these are some of
the very popular approaches that you
will see being employed both in research
papers as well as in practice about
seven to eight of them and you know
these are some of the commonly used
approach right so so far things seem
okay good but let's talk about some of
the challenges associated with how the
usage of these methods is in practice is
turning out to be and what we can do
about that okay so in order to explain
this so I'm going to talk about some of
our recent research on this disagreement
problem so this is a work that we did
where we conducted a study to understand
if and how these feature attribution
based explanation methods disagree with
each other in practice what actually
constitutes disagreement between these
explanations and how to formalize the
notion of the disagreement based on
practitioner inputs how do practitioner
has resolved disagreements when they
occur between these methods or how often
do they even run into that problem so
all of these were questions that we
wanted to investigate okay so to this
end what we did was we started with 30
minutes semi-structured interviews with
about 25 data scientists spanning
different startups and tech companies
and who were working in the explainable
AI teams they were using these tools
regularly on a daily basis in their work
to sort of provide insights to their
managers their clients and so on okay
and when we conducted these interviews
what we found was that 84 percent of
participants said that they often
encountered disagreement between these
explanation methods and when we asked
them what do they even mean by
disagreement how do they characterize
such disagreement they said the
following the top features that are
output by each of these methods seem
different the ordering among the stock
features seem different and the
direction or the sign of these top
feature contributions seem different and
the relative ordering of some features
of Interest also seem different right so
I'm going to talk more about these
different characterizations but the
interesting thing that we found is that
they focused on all these mismatching
top features feature ordering signs and
so on but not on the feature importance
values themselves right we didn't hear
people often saying that oh the values
of feature importance are different and
what what we did was we followed up a
bit more with some of the participants
and 24 out of 25 participants opined
that feature importance values output by
different methods are not directly
comparable because one is trying to use
shapely values uh one is trying to use
like linear regressions and other is
trying to do different variations of
gradients so they are sort of cognizant
of the fact that these feature
importance value news May themselves not
be directly comparable but yet there
seems to be this sort of expectation
that some kind of high level insights of
these methods should be comparable right
so because we are all kind of combining
them in this category of feature
attribution-based methods that seems to
be expectation when they try to use
these methods in practice in fact this
is very nicely summarized by this one
quote that we had in our study one of
the participants basically articulated
this problem very clearly which was you
know the values generated by different
explanation methods are clearly
different so I would not really
characterize the disagreement based on
that but I would at least want these
methods to give me consistent insights
right so the explanations should I agree
on what are the most important features
the ordering among them and so on for me
to derive consistent insights get a
consistent answer so that I can tell to
my bosses and clients but they don't and
that's a problem for me and and we just
don't know like how to go forward right
so after doing the study we basically
took all these inputs and we started
formalizing the notion of what
constitutes disagreement between two
explanations right and essentially we
try to sort of like put notations and
mathematical formulations on uh what
they exactly described for example
feature agreement in the top K was very
important which means what fraction of
the features in the top K features
matches between two explanations
generated by two different methods rank
agreement means not only should you know
the top K features match but also the
ranking or the ordering among them
should match sign agreement is basically
looking for the fraction of the features
which not only appear commonly in the
top five of two explanations but also
their signs or the directions of their
contributions match and sign rank is
basically uh with a fraction of features
which not only appear in the top K but
their rank should match within top K the
sign or the direction of contribution
should also match right so we just
captured the different things or the
criteria that these practitioners had uh
just into uh this kind of quantifiable
formulas right and we also looked at
like a couple of other things like
Spearman rank correlation coefficient
and pairwise rank agreement and in this
case practitioners were often having use
cases where they would try to ask
questions like oh is salary more
important than credit score right uh can
you tell me like which one is more
important for the prediction so they had
some features of interest that they
cared about and they wanted again
consistent answers from different
methods with respect to questions like
these uh so we also tried to capture
that with these two metrics one is rank
correlation just a simple Spearman rank
correlation coefficient the other is
pairwise rank agreement which is
basically the fraction of the feature
features in a set of features of
Interest we care about for which the
pairwise ranking or the ordering Remains
the Same across two explanations
and after coding up all these metrics we
actually went and carried out an
empirical analysis or to check uh which
of the explanation methods actually
disagree based on these metrics uh and
we did this kind of analysis with all
the postdoc explanation methods that I
just described very briefly for real
world data sets capturing tabular text
and image data eight different model
classes including you know basic models
like logistic regression to like large
deep Nets to rnns and so on and we
actually found several disagreements
between these methods like across all
these classes of models across different
types of data sets and you know between
all these different exclamation methods
right so that was a consistent pattern
that we observed which was also sort of
agreeing with what the practitioners had
to say to begin with okay so now now
that we are seeing this disagreement in
such a you know vast scale and
practitioners seem to be running
different methods at the same time on
the same input and then you know they're
hoping to observe similar insights but
they're not and that seems to be a big
problem for them in practice we wanted
to understand so how do practitioners
actually resolve this disagreement today
when they encounter it right so what
what is their strategy they're clearly
suffering from this problem like what do
they do in order to like address this
problem right so in order to get those
inputs we designed another study where
we sort of took two explanations that a
practitioners themselves uh say that
they maximally disagree and then we ask
these questions of okay so here are two
explanations that according to your
Criterion of you know two explanations
disagreeing are heavily disagreeing with
each other so now which one would you
pick and why or do you need additional
information so and we started showing
these pairwise explanations uh one from
each method so for example in this case
you see one from line one from kernel
shap we started showing them these kinds
of methods explanations that disagree
from different methods and then asking
which methods explanation would you pick
right to see or like just to understand
how they resolve this problem because
this is what they face in their
day-to-day workflows so what we found
was that uh and we also asked them why
they are making this choice right so
what we found was that practitioners
were actually choosing explanations that
were generated from methods for a
variety of reasons for example a
particular paper has Theory or it's a
more recently published paper so I'm
going to trust this methods output more
than the other methods output or the
explanations that are coming up are just
matching my own intuition better of what
should happen right or just the type of
data which is they're like yeah line
more shap is better for tabular data
gradients are good for image data right
so they were basically painting these
broad Strokes in terms of saying like
which which explanation would I pick and
in fact some of the top picked
algorithms are sharp and then smooth
grad and lime and integrated gradients
and if you see some of the Snippets here
you kind of observe some of these
patterns where people just say oh I'm
just more familiar with shap and you
know shap is just a more rigorous
approach because it has more theory in
the paper than lime so those are the
kinds of reasons that we often saw
coming up in our conversations with them
okay uh so what is this entire exercise
teaching us right so we are seeing that
feature attribution methods often
disagree in practice with respect to
basic insights uh and practitioners
adopt ad-hoc heuristics to resolve these
kinds of disagreements uh which is both
things that we need to address right so
now to think about it why are these
feature attribution methods disagreeing
like why do we see this pattern
happening is another important question
to ask and given that the feature
attribution methods disagree which
explanation method should we choose for
different kinds of data for different
kinds of applications that's also
another important question to ask right
in order to address the last two
questions uh we did some follow-up work
which basically tried to understand the
root causes of these disagreements and
also to figure out when these methods
disagree like how to proceed right so
which one to choose uh now in order to
sort of understand this what we showed
in our recent work is that all of these
feature attribution methods are
essentially local linear approximations
of the underlying model whether it is
shap or lime or C lime occlusion
gradients gradient times input smooth
grad integrated gradients but they're
all they're all doing local linear
approximations of the underlying model
but they are adopting different loss
functions and different Notions of local
neighborhoods right and we characterized
what exactly is the notion of local
neighborhood and the loss function each
of these approaches are using uh and we
clearly see differences between their
definitions of local neighborhood and
loss functions which is explaining why
we see these methods disagreeing using
this unified framework okay and we also
came up with this no free lunch theorem
for explanation methods which shows that
no single method can provide form
optimally across all possible
definitions of neighborhoods that we
just saw in the previous slide so that
also essentially eliminates this
argument of us being able to find the
perfect method that's going to work
across all possible definitions of what
a local neighborhood could be right and
just to kind of point out so the local
neighborhood could either be additive
continuous perturbations of a given
point or it could be like multiplicative
noise to a given point uh and so on and
then the kernels from which like these
noise itself is sampled could also be
different right so there are different
ways of thinking about local
neighborhood and there is no single
method that can perform optimally across
all these definitions of local
neighborhoods uh so then which method
should be used or based on this
framework that we just talked about one
way to think about which method to
choose is through a guiding principle
that relies on this uh local
approximation framework right so local
function approximation framework so
choose a method which recovers the
underlying model when the model is a
member of the explanation function plus
so that could be one rule of thumb when
deciding you know which method to choose
right and what we found was that and we
showed in some of our lemmas in this
paper is when your data is continuous
use methods that employ additive
continuous perturbations to generate
neighborhood for example smooth grad and
vanilla gradients and continuous version
of line are methods that employ
multiplicative continuous noise for
example integrated gradients gradient
times input and for binary data use
methods like lime kernel sharp and
occlusion which actually you used binary
noise methods which means essentially
perturbations will just be a feature
being on or off it's not about adding a
gaussian noise to a data point to
generate a perturbation right so
essentially we give some prescriptive
rules in terms of determining which
methods to choose when your data follows
a certain pattern in terms of the types
of the features that we have right then
there is also another way to think about
this which is which method to choose
another way to think about this question
is to actually use a bunch of evaluation
metrics that we do have today
and try to sort of compare the
explanations generated by different
methods using the various metrics that
we have available today right to this
end we actually built this framework
called open xai it's an open source
framework which can help us readily
evaluate and Benchmark the explanations
produced by all the state of the art
post hoc explanation methods uh and you
know the goal is to sort of generate
these uh systematic efficient and
reproducible evaluations of these
methods on various data sets using a set
of metrics and we have a very diverse
set of metrics which basically check or
measure the faithfulness and stability
and fairness of the explanations
produced by the state-of-the-art methods
and we also have dashboards to sort of
easily compare existing and new methods
across various data sets right so with
about 12 lines of code you would be able
to evaluate the faithfulness Properties
or stability Properties or fairness
properties of the explanations being
generated by these methods so that's
another approach where you know we sort
of use these metrics to evaluate or
compare each of the explanations being
generated by different methods if
they're different and pick the one that
sort of ranks high on the metrics that
are useful for your context are suited
for your context right so whether that I
just want to mention few points before I
conclude and take any further questions
so so far in this area of research
several methods have already been
proposed to explain machine learning
models as we just saw there's already a
myriad of methods and a lot more which
we do not even get to today uh the the
goal is or rather the the point at which
we are today in this field it becomes
very important to characterize these
methods and understand how they relate
to each other what are the connections
between them and understand which
methods can be useful under what
circumstances and it's also very
critical to bridge the gaps between
researchers and practitioners so one way
to or rather a couple of ways to address
the disagreement problems was you know
to sort of have this like comprehensive
evaluation framework that they could use
or even a theoretical understanding as
we just discussed but more importantly
it might also be a question of educating
practitioners better about what exactly
is coming out why are they're being
named a certain way why do we call all
these methods as you know feature
attribution based methods it's also
about potentially just Bridging the
education gaps so that there are these
misconceptions are not happening in
practice and you know hopefully nothing
bad happens as a result of those
misconceptions in practice right with
that I would like to pause here and
thank you all for your time and
attention and happy to take any further
questions thank you
okay
thank you so much uh we have time for
questions
hi thanks for the talk
um I guess I wanted to ask you about
um you know this no free lunch statement
and you know what I'm curious about is
like how it relates to uh you know
what's on the next slide which is oh
like you know in continuous settings
like feel free to like use these methods
otherwise use these methods right and
also I guess a related question is like
is there a notion of you know I I take
um some local region and you know if I'm
able to you know just like procure more
and more data in that region than like
do these methods converge to each other
in terms of performance so
um
yeah no uh great question and yes you
are right that so the next set of
results of like or I don't know phrase
this as a result but essentially these
prescriptions of for this type of data I
use this type of method is quite related
to the low freelance theorem itself
where we actually show that you know
these methods are able to recover the
underlying model if this is the
definition of the local neighborhood and
this other method which is implying a
different definition of local
neighborhood is not going to be able to
recover the underlying model when you
change the notion of the local
neighborhood right and that those uh
sort of like the pieces and the proof
are what are leading us to these
prescriptions as well so they are in
some sense like directly related right
uh and uh so that's uh also can you
sorry can you repeat the second part of
your question
um yeah I guess the second part is uh
like is there a notion of like you know
you use more data locally like when we
have access to more data then like
suddenly maybe they actually start
converging uh to each other in terms of
you know their predictions and
performance at least like Within These
like classes that you identify like
continuous versus binary data right yeah
so that is true for certain methods for
example lime and kernel shop if you have
enough samples of the perturbations in
the local neighborhoods they both
converge to the same explanation so
that's another result we have in another
paper but that's also because their
notion of local neighborhood is actually
similar both of them rely on this kind
of you know take a point and the way you
perturb it is your feature is either
turned on or off right like one or zero
so they employ the same notion of noise
which is this kind of binary
perturbations because of which when you
have like a lot of data or samples that
you can get from a local neighborhood
then those converge but there are also
other methods where you don't see that
convergence happening because the
fundamental notion of what the
perturbation is or what the local
neighborhood is is different so in spite
of having a lot of samples in the local
neighborhood you would get different
answers so some of them converge yes
with increased sample size but others
don't
thank you
[Music]
thanks uh so I have a question I was
wondering if uh any of these uh
techniques have been considered also in
a sequential context where you have uh
uh you know one uh decision and then
another it's based on the previous in
another and so on and have you um you
know can one then think of uh sort of
consistency of explanations across these
uh sequential decisions
yeah uh no that's a great question I
think uh
so far a lot of literature has focused
on this kind of One-Shot predictions uh
but off late there is more and more
interest in extending it into the
context of sequential decision making
also in the context of these larger
language models or like diffusion type
models or clip models uh but a lot of
those I I think the what people are
finding is the strategies that I
described today and which are often like
employed quite a bit in the context of
these One-Shot prediction models uh are
failing when we try to like extend them
to sequential decision making or even
other complex pre-trained models right
so I think that basically calls for uh
or emphasizes the need for new kinds of
approaches but at the same time it's
also saying that the promise of these
kinds of approaches to those settings is
limited and we might have to look for
new approaches all together so there are
some Works where I think Tim Miller had
some work on this kind of explanations
for sequential decisions but they try to
use the causal graphs and then try to
get those explanations and that's a very
different approach than what we talked
about today uh but yeah I think more
exploration needed these approaches are
not really fitting well in that context
so I think necessity for different kinds
of other approaches to be explored there
got it thanks and relatedly uh do you
also look at sort of consistency of
explanations across the the space of
examples uh
yeah you can stream to
yeah so uh there is some work on that uh
so thinking about the consistency of the
explanations being generated across
samples uh and in fact like the the
outcome or the you know summary of that
result is that some of these approaches
especially when they're not sort of
converging like for example lime or
kernel shop and so on uh they can cause
problems with consistency uh so which is
why the convergence are having enough
samples in the local neighborhood is
important uh in order to ensure
consistency across samples as well uh
but that's another result in other
people so there has been some
exploration in that area as well
some things I think uh we don't have any
more questions thank you so much Hima
thank you thanks a lot thanks for having
me
yeah we have a